now let's get to
the news and
aaron rodgers knocked tim tebow off the
top of the stack the afternoon that the
draft began thankfully that was the last
thing that anyone wanted to do was delve
into the possibility of a guy who's been
out of the nfl for nearly a decade
coming back as some sort of a gimmick
with the jaguars well now
now that the jaguars are in this
weird holding pattern of we're going to
do it we're going to do it we're going
to do it we just haven't done it yet
basically yeah tebow is knocking aaron
rodgers
off the top stack at least for a little
while and we're going to talk some more
about tebow because it really is
imminent let's let's not take my word
for it as if anyone ever would take my
word for anything here's urban meyer
coach of the jaguars talking to chris
collinsworth on the chris collinsworth
podcast about
whether or not the jaguars will be
signing tim tebow hired us
yeah we have not signed tim uh there's a
thought going around you know he uh
he was in the best shape of his life
asked to see if he could work out with a
couple of our coaches i wasn't even
there
and uh they came back to me and said wow
this guy's in incredible shape and i
said then i went another time and
watched him try him out
and they said go work on these things he
comes back later
they try him out again i'm not there
they come in and they said wow you know
this guy's ball skills he's a great
athlete he looks like he's 18 years old
not 20 whatever he is 33
and i said guys you don't understand now
this guy is
you know he's the most competitive
maniac you're ever going to talk to and
let's give it a shot and i have not
decided if we're going to do that or not
yet i'm getting close i got to make a
decision here pretty soon
you know there are certain people i
really would like to play poker with in
the nfl i think urban meyer is one of
them all right let's give it a shot we
haven't decided to do it yet let's give
it a shot we're not we
well let's give it a shot once he says
let's give it a shot it's over the stuff
you say afterward doesn't matter let's
give it a shot well we haven't done it
yet we haven't done it yet but i just
said let's give it a shot so it was just
like what he said about trevor lawrence
to peter king weeks ago it was clear
they were going to draft trevor lawrence
and he stopped short of saying we're
going to draft trevor lawrence but it
was clear from the context and the words
that's what they were going to do
they're signing tim tebow i would be
shocked if not i would be shocked
and i don't know if this is just some
sort of a of a slow easing into a hot
bath that we can all kind of get used to
it it's taken a couple of weeks you know
for it to really come out and maybe this
is aimed at people in the organization
that may not be thrilled with it i don't
know why this is taking so long
they worked him out three times if if my
understanding of what myers said is
accurate three times at least they
worked him out so i feel like it's
coming it's just a question of when yeah
i mean me too i mean i mean again you
know first off urban meyer he cherishes
tim tebow he does you could see him just
there in that little conversation with
chris collinsworth i mean just the the
look on his face the things he says you
know oh he's gonna you know work harder
than any human you've ever seen before
and everything like that listen urban
meyer has been a big believer in tim
tebow from the college days i mean
that's and that's where you know again
that's where i think it rubs some people
wrong here you know i think at the base
level i don't know how much football
value tim tebow has on the football
field we i really don't know and of
course we don't know what he can do as a
tight end he's never done it before and
he hasn't played oh he has oh i know
that one play over and over and over
again yes great route yes off his head
great ball skills yes right so
okay but now i mean hey it it's more
just looking more than anything and i
think what bothers some people is just
an old coach doing a guy a favor and
like hey yeah buddy i'll give you 27
strikes to fail in sports don't you just
keep coming back and i think that's
where it bothers a lot of athletes
players people like that where they just
don't feel like
they've been given those opportunities
so much and but but this is a rare
scenario where a coach has really bought
into one guy
i went back and found the story we wrote
at pft
when tim tebow retired from a baseball
career that didn't quite make it to the
major leagues although
the mets did everything they could
to push it there for
financial reasons fine fine they're
prerogative it's it's it's an
entertainment
business more than anything else you
want to put a guy on the field who
really shouldn't be there because you
can sell a bunch of his jerseys and
people will come to the games good we
got 162 games you got to get people to
show up but
when he retired from baseball
i speculated he was going to end up in
jacksonville not as a player i never
dreamed it would be as a player i
thought it would be as a coach bring him
in as some sort of assistant to the
assistant to the assistant to something
just to have him in the building because
of that cronyism we see a lot of
nepotism in football there's plenty of
cronyism too taking care of friends
having guys around that you can trust
guys you know guys you want to help guys
you like guys you choose to spend the
time with
it's a stretch though chris this is a
big stretch to make him a player yes
big stretch like you're that's the way
you're right that's part of life that's
part of businesses everything like that
that's okay
if you've got history with the guy in
the nfl and he's played maybe recently
in the nfl to go along with that okay
it's okay maybe it's okay for the
coaches hey that's under we understand
that the players are going to understand
that but
players are not going to understand this
that's where it's a stretch to what
you're saying they're not they're going
to go wait there's plenty of there's
free agent tight ends out there there's
other guys in college football who who
weren't drafted and things like that
that you could make the moves and do
those type of things and that's where
it's a bad look it's a total stretch
from that standpoint you know there's no
there's no merit to the signing and it
makes no sense this is not aldon smith
i've sat out for five years and oh wait
that's right i was one of the best edged
pass rushers in football and i'm not
changing positions i'm coming back to
play the same position i was dominant at
before the nfl and i had my issues this
is nowhere near that that's where it's
crazy it's crazyville and that's where i
i don't understand it i don't i don't
think it's a good look for urban meyer
or the jags really
jeff darlington of espn said yesterday
not everyone in the jaguars building is
thrilled about the potential tim tebow
arrival that's a point chris you made
yesterday how do you sell this in the
locker room how do you get the other
players to accept without the side eye
or the eye roll or any other
facial expression or bodily gesture that
would suggest what the hell are you
doing coach how do you pull that off and
i think this is another example
of a guy who's never coached at the nfl
level in any capacity making the
adjustment on the fly you can't bring
the i'm the emperor of the college
football program i'll do what i want
yeah it's not gonna work to an nfl
locker room it's not gonna work it's not
gonna work you don't lord over
nfl players the way that you lord over
college players and if an nfl player has
an issue with what you're doing
he's gonna talk to his buddy about it
and they're going to talk to their buddy
about it and you're going to have an
issue in your locker room that you don't
know how to deal with because in
columbus and gainesville every other
stop where urban meyer's been
he can nip it in the bud pretty quickly
because they're all scared crapless of
him
yeah i mean he's he's been the dictator
he's been like you said the the god on
campus and everything like that it is
different you know maybe you could have
got away with that 20 30 years ago
coming from college to the nfl right but
it's just a different player all
together in the league so i you know
again
we don't hear like those generals who
are you know always yelling orders and
get your toes on the line and all that
that coach doesn't really exist anymore
in the nfl
that's non-existent we saw that a little
like right with like greg schiano and
some of that was the the kellen winslow
chant right greg toes on the line yeah
exact attitude doesn't work against
grown men exactly it's a disaster we saw
the last guy we really saw with it is
tom coughlin maybe right who he even had
to go like wait i can't be the general
i'd like to be i gotta like bow to the
players a little bit and change here
it's 2007 eight whatever so yes oh wait
did he remove the patches from his shirt
when he decided to no longer be the
general he probably did he hung up his
medals in the closet for a little while
and said i'll be back in a little while
after this but yeah uh urban meyer's
gotta gotta be careful of that so um
that's that's gonna be one of these
moves right now that's gonna look like
hey i'm the king i like this guy
and i wanna give him another chance and
of course the players are gonna accept
it because he is the king but it is
gonna make them look out of the side eye
and go like man why are we doing favors
for this guy what did he do to deserve
to be here why is he taking my reps
right now during seven on seven i mean
there's all those type of issues and
that's what urban meyer is going to have
to be very careful about and political
about with managing this situation
one thing i struggled with yesterday was
the obvious colin kaepernick comparison
yeah and the quick knee-jerk wait a
minute
and we talked about it the strongest
argument against kaepernick now is he
hasn't played in the nfl in four years
well
this guy hasn't played the nfl in eight
seasons 2013 through 2020 no regular
season appearances for tim tebow
so it blows out of the water the idea
that well it's been four years now that
ship has sailed but it occurred to me
yesterday afternoon there is one common
thread between tebow and kaepernick
urban meyer is the only coach
that would have ever signed tim tebow
there's no land rush for tim tebow right
there's no buzz that's making its way
through 32 nfl front offices hey did you
hear tim tebow's in the greatest shape
of his life did you hear he had three
awesome workouts in jack should we call
tim tim tebow should should do we should
should we dare we bring tim tebow no
nobody cares nobody else is going to
touch tim tebow ever there's one man
in the world who would sign tim tebow
and that man is now the head coach of
the jacksonville jaguars and i say that
because i think there's one guy
in the world who would sign colin
kaepernick and that guy is your friend
and mine jim harbaugh yeah yeah coach at
michigan if he'd gotten the jacksonville
job he's signing tim tebow now maybe
there would have been some pushback
internally maybe shot khan would have
said you know we're running a business
here we're trying not to scare fans away
we want to allure them to come to the
games but harbaugh is the one guy who
has consistently spoken out in favor of
kaepernick back when all this started he
was on this program you signed colin
kaepernick you will win championships
with an s on the end so
i
the the easy explanation is why tebow
and why not kaepernick because urban
meyer is the coach of the jaguars not
jim harbaugh that i mean that's it i
mean we said that yesterday that's where
i mean it doesn't make any sense from
the standpoint of football and what he
can do from you on the field but it
makes sense in a whole lot of other ways
and we've talked about the business
aspect of it in jacksonville you know i
feel like the shad khan even him coming
out last week and recognizing this
conversation that was another step into
like hey let's gauge the temperature and
make everybody feel comfortable that
this is coming to your point and
everything like that so uh but but that
and hey the world and the nfl especially
i mean it's become more of like not it's
not what you know it's who you know and
that's all through the ranks and that's
what part of the problems we have the
issues and you know the college and i
mean uh in in the coaching ranks as far
as lack of diversity and things like
that it's because hey i know this guy i
want to work with him i want to do this
i worked with him you know i trust him
like you said all of those type of
things so tebow is getting the benefit
of the doubt because he's from the area
he is a god-like figure down in that
area
and you're right the main thing is he
has a coach who
thinks he's the greatest thing since
sliced bread i mean he treats him like
it's a son you know an extension of his
family and i think that's just too hard
for urban meyer to like kind of close
the door on that i think he's got a
piece of his heart that belongs to tim
tebow and that's why we're going to see
him there
and there is a fundamental difference
beyond the fact that he's not a member
of his family urban meyer doesn't own
the team that is the firewall that folks
don't understand when it comes to nfl
franchises when you own the team
and you are going to eventually age and
die and you have children
you groom your children to take over the
business otherwise they're going to sell
it and there it goes it's gone when
you're the coach that doesn't mean that
it's a blank check to hire anyone you
want without regard to merit we hear all
the time football is a meritocracy and
chris i would submit to you it's not
worse now when it comes to nepotism and
cronyism i think we've evolved to the
point where we're sensitive to it
because it takes away opportunities for
others based on merit yeah plain and
simple right i'm hiring my kid to be the
assistant strength coach was your kid
the best choice i don't care it's my kid
i'm hiring my friend to be the assistant
quarterbacks coach i'm giving the
quality control job to my nephew
you know
these are things that turn the idea of
merit on its head and tim tebow
is the player equivalent of that you're
right right now right the crony the
buddy the pal the adopted son whatever
you want to say this is a guy who
doesn't have the skill to play in the
nfl but he's going to be playing in the
nfl or at least he's going to be on nfl
roster and and and you know i i saw some
tweets yesterday that basically hey you
know they do crazy things from time to
time george plimpton
once played quarterback for the lions
for a book he was writing or whatever
the case was
right but call it a gimmick it's a
gimmick yeah gimmicks happen right this
is a gimmick
this isn't real we're being led to
believe it's real when you see urban
meyer explain to chris collinsworth all
these great things he did he had this
workout oh he's great he's got great
ball skills except for that one play
when he played tight end pay no
attention to that play please but
otherwise trust me he's great he's ready
don't sell me on it being a meritocracy
coach when it's a gimmick
just just admit that it's a gimmick
because it is it's a gimmick chris i
mean it's a gimmick yes to all of us but
is it a gimmick to you know to urban
meyer not to him
tim tebow no it's not damn i'm not sure
it is to urban evil i mean urban meyer
either i think he looks at the guy like
you know i think if he sits there and he
wants to move a mountain he can he might
be able to move that mountain i think he
looks at team
tim tebow like that he does maybe
everybody else that's coached in the nfl
since 2012 is wrong
maybe everyone else has gotten it wrong
they have missed this diamond in the
rough antonio gates
in training they could have had him they
could have had the original calling
winslow they could have had tony
gonzalez and they all missed out because
they all didn't have the foresight to
have this guy show up run routes and
demonstrate that he's in the greatest
shape of his life is isn't it funny
anytime anyone is ever in any shape
they're in the greatest shape of their
life of course at some point you you you
you can't continuously be in the
greatest shape of your life at some
point it is going to well that's another
thing too
hot dog we're talking about an athlete
who ran four seven at the combine and
has not played football in eight years i
mean do we think does people think he's
gonna be faster he's gonna be faster
than when he came out of college oh
that's right no he won't you know and
then i think that's like i was i was
texting with an ex-teammate
you know the other uh yesterday and this
came up just real quick right but i
think he brought up a good point and the
fact that
basically saying like
you know
the guy had it the league wanted him to
move to tight end and do those things
and he wanted to give him a chance there
and he said no no no no no to the point
where he quit the sport because he
wouldn't do it and then he comes back
because what now he doesn't know what to
do baseball didn't work so now i'll
change and i'll come back you know and i
think that's what it say it or not
players might say it they might not i
don't know but that's gonna piss players
off because nobody has given that chance
nobody almost in the history of football
has been given those opportunities and
with this time of day right now 2021 and
everything that's going on in the world
sorry that's part of the conversation
here and it just has a bad look on the
optics because of that that's that's
what i came but i thought that was a
valid point there too by an ex-teammate
who i don't want to
put on blast but i think it does rub
some people the wrong way smart
especially ex-athletes ex-football
players
and current football players and current
ones right the wrong way right there is
a constant churning of guys at the
bottom of a roster trying to get on a
team stay on a team busting their asses
never checked out never went and played
some other sport and ventured back to
football and and now just expects to
show up and be giving preferential
treatment by his former college coach
and the way meyer explained it if you
were paying attention closely to what he
said earlier in the clip we played
tebow reached out to them i i don't know
whether or not i choose to believe that
since it is a gimmick and they're trying
to make us think it's not a gimmick so i
i i reserve the right to call bs on any
aspect of what's said about it because
the whole thing is coded in bs
but frankly sorry all due respect we
we're here to to to shoot the world of
as much bs as we can yeah but uh
yeah there's there's reason for people
to be
resentful within the jaguars
organization there's reason for other
players to be resentful the devin bush
tweet that we mentioned earlier i mean
devin bush
he's the one that pointed out yesterday
tebow got a job before kaepernick wait
till we play jacksonville i don't know
what the z's are supposed to mean i'll
leave it to the eye of the beholder to
interpret it and then devin bush got
upset because bleacher report
you know mentioned that he said what he
said i always love it when what the hell
is up with this lately
people in the nfl they say something
for attention
we give them attention
and then they get mad because we gave
them attention
it's the hey everybody look at me
what the hell are you looking at that's
the mindset it's weird i i don't it's a
it's a thing with our society right now
like the hell with sports it's like you
know you're going down the highway right
now and if somebody the the person in
front of you is driving down the middle
of the lane on both lanes right right
right on the white line and texting and
you pull up to them and give them the
finger and they're mad at you they're
like how dare you call i mean it's it's
a common thing right now how dare you
yeah how dare you call me out for
breaking the law and looking at my
instagram why i'm driving 90. what a
jerk you are let me just let me just
make a general observation yeah i tend
to be a student of the human condition
right when you give someone the finger
right whatever the context yes whatever
happened to precede the giving of the
finger chances are the reaction's not
going to be a positive well that's just
well you're right but you know what i
feel like a real good human who might be
doing that and on instagram driving
between two lanes and then somebody like
honked and gave him the finger like dude
what are you doing i'd be like man
you're right i'm sorry what the hell am
i doing give him a little wave and like
get back on my two hands on the steering
wheel but no did one of us actually give
the finger did one of us actually give
the finger oh we're doing that
i don't know i think i stuck up i think
i did this i think i did that i don't
think i actually no no no
okay good good no i'm just we're saying
i was nervous there for a second i
didn't yeah because once you start
demonstrating i know talk with your
hands you talk about giving the finger
you just never know no i wasn't sure
yeah you're right when you said it but i
was like oh no maybe i did
but i didn't mean i but i didn't mean to
change your subject but yes come on
devin bush like what do you think you're
the middle linebacker from michigan
you're a first round pick from
pittsburgh like we're gonna look at your
instagram we're all looking don't have
an instagram then if you don't want
people to pay attention do it
that makes no sense i don't understand
that either mike but uh let's address
some of the narratives back to emerge
yesterday on twitter uh pete has
collected some of them joshua bell how
do you know that tebow doesn't deserve
the job when you didn't see his workout
what joshua bell said is if you haven't
seen his workout you probably shouldn't
say he doesn't deserve anything for all
we know he did a fantastic job at the
tryouts yeah for all for all we know for
all we know he ran a 4-5 for all we know
he chased that chicken and he caught it
for all we know he's going to eat
lightning and he's going to crap thunder
but i think we're allowed to apply
common sense and logic to this and say
this isn't some magical aligning of
metaphysical forces that all of a sudden
have turned this guy into a tight end
yes exactly this is someone doing a
favor for a buddy right period and
common sense and he's and joshua bell
he's never played the position before
other than one play
like this so i i don't i don't know what
else you want to say there
like okay yeah the workout looked good
great
like listen
like no disrespect but
you know you if you give me a month you
give eli manning a month all right and
just say hey let's train and work on
just running tight end routes and things
like that we don't have to block anybody
all we have to do is go run routes and
catch the ball we're going to look
pretty good in a workout like so what
that means nothing he is we know he's in
he's an in-shape athlete he's not like
some fool
i get that but that that means nothing
to me the fact that he was in shape for
a workout and trust me it didn't blow
anybody out of the water to that extent
urban can say all he wants to chris
collinsworth if it blew him out of the
water to that extent like jacksonville
people that were there they would have
probably called other coaches around the
league and said something and then you
would have maybe been like man tebow's
right like come on yeah that's an insane
that day if he blows you out of the
water you sign in that day exactly we
don't have three workouts right exactly
we've got a new and improved tim tebow
not only is he in the greatest shape of
his life he somehow transformed his
natural skills beyond a point that
anyone ever would have expected and if
we don't sign him someone else is going
to figure it out and they're going to
get him on the team we have a potential
to have a secret weapon here it's
common sense
and workouts say nothing workouts are
done in the nfl just to go like wait
let's see if the guy's healthy let's
just see him in person it's not like you
know it's not again they're gonna be
evaluated for what they've done on the
field or what they do on the field
ultimately but like if it was a real
tight end a real tight end again they're
gonna have watched him on film
now they're gonna have a workout only
just to go hey let's see him run and
catch make sure he's healthy see
everything he can do everything
physically that's it you're not going
like oh he really improved uh oh he's
coming out of brakes full speed man look
at that swin swim move against imaginary
no one in front of him in this workout
like no
that's not what a workout's about he
couldn't have proved to anybody to the
point of like during a workout that it's
like oh he can do it he can play tight
end look he collapsed the right side of
the line on that run play and then the
next play got open against miles jack
he's ready no come on stop that
so i don't need to know joshua bell i
know it wasn't so great that he needs to
be signed on an nfl football team i'm
sorry that maybe that's not the best
answer in the world but so colin baird
says
whose reps is he stealing who's in the
jaguars tight end room right now that
that is tied to this narrative of hey
they they have
no one at the position they need the
help well okay the easy answer to that
is there are qualified individuals out
there who are looking for jobs there are
people who have played tight end in the
nfl yeah very much like to continue
their careers there's no shortage of
tight ends there's there's no
tight end pipeline that's been hacked
and shut down by the russians that there
are tight ends galore if you want a
tight end
it's yeah you you're not happy with the
tight end you have you go find one of
the ones from the qualified group of
tight ends who are out there that you
can bring in and work out and put on
your team who have played the position
at some respectable level and have shown
they can do it that's what you do you
don't go you don't go you know
for some sideshow routine to bring in to
play tight end that's the easy answer to
that one yeah exactly i mean you said it
right yeah exactly you know whose reps
is he stealing yeah some of the guys
that we don't know their names or don't
know a lot about them but they are tight
ends in the nfl he's stealing their reps
and their ability to get better that way
and then like who's in the jaguars tight
end right now i mean again it's not a
strong group i understand that tim tebow
doesn't make us stronger what
like get the hell out of here i mean
it's always when you say it out loud it
almost makes it sound like it's weaker
like that doesn't make sense you didn't
make the room better that way it's not
like uh we got tim in here now guys the
tight end room's complete we're good
guys we're good we're not looking for
free agents anymore like get out of here
well that means nothing and he does not
improve the tight end room and all the
things you said are really spot on
another one he can be the jaguars
version of taste oh my gosh get the hell
out that people thought taysom hill was
a waste of a roster spot as well he ran
a 4-5 yeah he went up four four four
four at his pro day ran four four four
even better right faster right
and like
i mean legit explosion and let's not
forget taste some hill like legit arm
this is not like tim tebow where we just
throw fluttering ducks in the air a
quarterback all the time either so no
it's not the same and i hear i hear
people we got one here right at
spaghetti he could also play a taste of
hill roll he's an incredible athlete
he's not the same athlete as taste of
mill takes them at hill can beat alvin
kamara in a race
tim tebow cannot that's insane and if
you want to run that offense that you
have two running backs put
travis atn at quarterback and let him
run the ball and james robinson can be
next to him running the ball so that's
that's not an option either like that
that would not be a realistic thing for
anyone credible in the nfl to be
thinking about let me get the guy who
hasn't played eight years wasn't really
that fast to begin with but now
hey i'm going to give him some reps of
quarterback and we drafted the number
one quarterback in the draft but we're
gonna put him on the bench for a few
plays so tebow can run behind the
pulling guard okay get the hell out of
here people are losing their damn minds
over this
and let me tell you a quick take some
hill story just to illustrate the
athleticism that he possesses right
back before anyone knew about taysom
hill and he was just a special teamer
on the saints and he was running down on
kick coverage punt coverage whatever i
think was primarily kickoff coverage
when you got to run down the field
he was so fast it made the other guys
look slow and they'd get called out in
the front room for not busting their
asses down the field because hill was so
much faster than everyone else and it it
popped on film that hey hey guys come on
get the let out i mean look at taysom's
down there where are you it's like yeah
because he is faster than almost
everybody in the building and and that's
the difference between taysom hill and
tim tebow taysom hill is a legitimate
nfl competitor tim tebow at this point
is a gimmick period yeah um here's
another one and this one has
i think a little more
to unpack than the basic knee jerk hey
you're just wrong
the idea that this is like taking a
basketball player who's never played in
the nfl never played football and and
you know and antonio gates a jimmy
graham this is a guy who's a project
we're going to make him a tight end
brian wilder pointed this out on twitter
miami just signed a kid who's never
played football as a tight end he played
basketball only that's jibri blount from
north carolina central the son of of uh
hall of famer mel blunt but that's a
clear project that's not a gimmick that
is a we're taking a guy who is a lump of
clay right can be molded into a player
and has the body of the perfect tight
end already and it has all the
measurables you want that have we've
already seen nfls and the nfl tight ends
have these measurables in this size and
it translates to greatness not
ex-quarterbacks who are six one two
hundred and twenty pounds but go ahead
keep going here yeah no not that my
point but this is not a lump of clay
this is a broken cracked dried out bowl
that that already the clay was turned
into something and it didn't work and
like you said he had his chance eight
nine years ago to become a tight end and
he said he didn't want to do it right
and he and he left the sport and that's
that so this is far different than than
you know panning for gold or looking for
a needle in a haystack and finding the
right build the right frame the right
guy who who can come in and you can you
can almost manufacture in a laboratory
into a perfect nfl tight end far
different uh than that but yes you know
is is gerbry blunt ready to walk in and
play tight end of the nfl right now no
but there's a ceiling for him
that just isn't there for tim tebow no
exactly right i mean they're hoping to
get a guy like an antonio gates or tony
gonzalez or some of the other stories
we've heard about you know jimmy graham
right it's those kind of those guys are
freaks of nature first off and this guy
jabiri blunt has some of those skills
too that's why he's been giving that
shot it's like hey he's a he's got you
know some size we like that makes sense
of the position and then he has some
physical things he does that are like
really special so let's see if we can
work with him
none of that is
that's not a part of the conversation
with tebow yeah i know he's going to
work hard and do all those things but
you know that's the other thing too you
hear mike like well he might help the
culture down there what
like crazy first off you don't want tim
tebow framing your culture really you
don't you'd like trevor lawrence and
some of the other leaders to take
advantage of that and to like to say how
silly that is people aren't gonna like
miles jack's not gonna be like oh man
tim tebow our nine tight end on the
rosters out here catching a few extra
balls let me stay out here and work too
like come on that's not the kind of guy
or story they follow here that's this is
fairy tale land some of this stuff
people are talking about right now
think about this too
the day that the draft was due to begin
the day that trevor lawrence was going
to hear his name called to cap a process
where he had taken a back seat
to trey lance mack jones justin fields
nobody was paying attention nobody cared
because everybody knew it was
pre-ordained lance
trevor lawrence was the guy
and then just hours before the process
begins they leaked to nfl media that
they may be signing tim tebow if you're
trevor lawrence you're like what the
hell yeah i'm the new face of the
franchise i'm the number one overall
pick in the draft what the hell's tim
tebow have to do with anything so you
know you want to change the culture you
make him
a an assistant coach you find a job for
him so he's in the building you'll wedge
him onto the organizational chart
because he has value to your team you
don't give him a roster spot
with an eye toward giving him one of the
53 roster spots or finding a way to
force him onto the field just to prove
that you were right
because because here's what will happen
they'll come up with some play chris
that you or i could have run and caught
a touchdown pass from the three-yard
line they'll come up with something you
know that's the standard
trick play that that pops an offensive
lineman open for a touchdown like the
one we almost saw in the super bowl
they'll do something like that and
that'll be vindication for urban meyer
no
no
it's it it won't be but but i guarantee
you we're going to see him in uniform
and we're going to see him play if they
sign him if they sign it's possible that
this is the
the byproduct of the chris doyle
situation where they hired him they got
the blow back and they had to move on
from him it may be that they're
they're making sure you know speak now
forever hold your peace yeah we're gonna
sign tim tebow we're gonna sign tim
tebow just to to flesh out the reaction
before they finally do it yeah i mean
maybe you know maybe they are just
gauging this gauging the temperature
around this conversation and all that
but listen we roasted rogers and
everybody did for hijacking the draft
tim tebow tried to do the same type of
thing
i i don't know who represents him right
now pro i think it's caa whatever it is
but that was a planned attack he wasn't
signed by a team nothing had happened
yes they had obviously reached out to
urban they released that information too
before the draft i mean jacksonville
didn't they weren't like hey this is our
big night it's the one of the biggest
drafts of our organization's history hey
let's let's put out that tebow nugget
and get everybody go like no no that was
released by tebow so like again if we're
gonna roast rogers for doing that type
of thing this is far more egregious and
ridiculous that he did it it is i mean
rogers had a point to be angry and had
like some true things in his corner to
where he could you could justify it uh
so that's where i guess that rubs me
wrong that way and but for the rogers
thing it would have worked yes because
it was just minutes after the tebow leak
that shefty decided now was the time to
let the world know that
aaron rodgers is disgruntled he'd known
about it for i don't wanna
regardless
rogers whoever wanted it out yeah trump
tim tebow before the tim tebow story
could get off the ground
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports